that's true anything specifically you
guys information you need right now we
got that call lets-a-go you need to be
here tonight at 7 o'clock
[Music]
[Music]
yeah we're gonna start with the donor
and I think Katie will pie get down
there by about 9:00 a.m. they still
envisioning 24:32 every time yeah I
imagine I mean I think you know I'm
thinking in my head 30 hours so right
between that time frame that you're
talking about are you having any second
thoughts
I think you could kind of hear initially
but on the donor we're going to not
[Music]
the main goal is is this that's the main
goal this we're gonna do a little bit up
here but it's not a major part of what
work what they do
Thank You Your mercies that are new
every day we thank you for this
opportunity
[Music]
in order to get to the tissues in the
create space for what we're
transplanting on all this has to be
removed including bone here on here bone
here bone here and we need access to it
while still preserving things that
makers filter by Katie there's always
the risk that in the middle of working
to prepare Katie
we couldn't have to stop and be luck
with virtually nothing because the donor
could become unstable
Katie said to me if something happens to
me during the transplant I don't want
you to be upset I was probably a lot
more nervous than she was
once we make a decision there's no going
back
[Music]
you